What happens when you keep a peeled banana
out in the open?
The banana gradually deteriorates and we find
several tiny creatures hovering over it!
These tiny creatures are commonly called fruit flies.
They’re annoying right?
But did you know that these small wonders
are one of the most powerful tools for geneticists?
Sounds hard to believe!
But these fruit flies are used as model organisms
in Genetics.
Let me tell you an extremely important and
unbelievable fact!
Did you know that the common fruit fly, Drosophila
melanogaster and humans have genes that are
almost 60% similar to each other?
You heard me right!
Just a total of eight chromosomes in this
tiny creature contain around 60% genes similar
to humans!
And not only this, but the fruit fly is also
used as a model to study the most serious
neurodegenerative disorders including Parkinson’s
and Alzheimer’s.
So this little creature is nothing short of
a miracle for us!
But who thought of using these tiny model
organisms for experiments?
Well, the use of Drosophila melanogaster as
model organisms dates back to several years!
However, the organism rose to fame with the
experiments of the father of experimental
genetics : Thomas Hunt Morgan!
Following Boveri and Sutton’s Chromosomal
theory of inheritance, Morgan and his colleagues
carried out many experiments on the common
fruit fly which served as further confirmation
for the theory!
Let us have a look at what experiments he
actually performed, and what results he got!
For that, let us travel back in time and reach
the early years of the 20th century!
It was around the early years of 1900s that
Thomas Hunt Morgan started working on fruit
flies with a determination to find something new!
Did he really find something interesting?
Well yes!
One fine day, in a vial containing red-eyed
flies, Morgan found something strange!
He could spot a male fly with white coloured eyes!
Morgan knew that this is a special type of
mutant and experiments with this will lead
to a new path in Genetics!
So how did he plan his experiments?
What was the procedure?
Let us find that out in the next part!
Imagine you are working in a lab with the
little fruit fly!
One fine day, you find an unusual mutant among
the other wild types.
Wild types means the ones normally found in
nature, or the natural forms to be precise!
So the ‘mutant form’ means the ones that
have undergone some random or unusual changes.
For example, red eye colour is the natural
or wild type of variety in fruit flies.
But the white eye colour is a mutant form.
So what would you do if you find a mutant
type of fruit fly in a vial one day?
I am sure anyone would simply grab the opportunity
and begin experimenting with this unique variety!
The father of experimental genetics, Thomas
Hunt Morgan was not an exception to this!
One fine day, he found a unique mutant in
one of his vials while working in the lab.
The mutant was a white eyed male fruit fly.
Soon, he realised that the exclusive mutant
was an ideal model for carrying several experiments
that would lead us to new paths in genetics!
Let us begin understanding how Morgan carried
out his famous experiments on the fruit fly
which later proved the Chromosomal theory
of inheritance better!
Morgan crossed the white eyed male with a
wild type, that is a red eyed female.
The F1 generation had all the offsprings with
red coloured eyes.
This showed that red eye colour is a dominant trait!
Okay!
What next then?
Morgan stepped ahead to cross the F1 hybrids.
What he expected was a 3 to 1 ratio.
That is what we get in the F2 generation, right?
And what should the genotypic ratio be?
It should be 1 to 2 to 1.
And is this what Morgan obtained?
Yes!
Morgan obtained 3 red eyed flies and one white
eyed fly in the F2 generation.
Also, the genotypic ratio was 1 to 2 to 1.
So did these results suggest that Mendel’s
experiments were correct?
Kind of Yes!
Mendel had obtained ratios for plants.
Here, we considered animals for the experiment.
That is why, although Morgan had obtained
the ratios just like Mendel did, things didn’t
end here!
Morgan obtained only one white eyed fly in
the F2 generation.
But note that this fly is a MALE.
This unfolds a lot of hidden ambiguities.
Why didn’t he obtain a white eyed FEMALE?
Did this hint at something?
That’s a right guess!
The results not only gave a proof of the Chromosomal
theory of Inheritance, but also helped in
shining light on newer concepts.
Morgan assumed that the eye colour genes that
are passed down the generation are sex linked.
Now what could this be?
Let us get introduced to this term first.
We know that chromosomes in organisms are
of two types.
One type is called autosomes, which are simply,
not the sex chromosomes.
And the second category is this sex chromosomes
themselves which determine the sex of the
organism.
These chromosomes are usually represented
with the letters “X” and “Y”.
In most organisms, individuals with “X”
chromosomes are females, while individuals
with one “X” and one “Y” are males.
Getting back to our concept, sex linked implies
the characters or traits linked to the sex
chromosomes.
So the characters which usually pass down
the generations with respect to a particular
sex will be sex linked.
So in this case, Morgan did not stop at the
fact that his results confirmed the chromosomal
theory.
He went a step ahead and put forth the assumption
that the genes for eye colour are present
on the “X” chromosome in the fruit fly.
In the next part, let us understand what Morgan
had to say about this!
We are in the midst of studying Thomas Morgan’s
experiment.
We have seen so far that Morgan crossed a
white eyed male with a red eyed female which
is the wild type.
The F1 generation had all the offsprings with
red coloured eyes.
Also, when he obtained the F2 generation,
it made him assume that the genes for eye
colour are present on the “X” chromosome
in the fruit flies.
Now to understand this better, let us carry
out a theoretical cross.
To begin with, let us denote the chromosomes
as “X” and “Y” for representation
purposes.
But if we use “X” and “Y” to represent
the chromosomes, then how do we represent
the genes on these chromosomes?
For that, we will write additional letters
in superscript!
So let’s say we write the letter “w”
in lower case to represent the genes for white
coloured eyes.
The red eyed phenotype will then be represented
by the letter “w” in lower case, having
a plus sign after it.
Do you think this representation is strange?
Well, that’s how it is usually done in genetics.
The first letter of the mutant type is used
for denoting the alleles.
Hence, we use the letter “w” for representing
the mutant allele for white eyes.
We simply add the plus sign to it to denote
the wild type.
So instead of using the letter “r” for
red eye colour, we use “w plus”.
Also, we need to know that the wild type which
is the red eye trait is DOMINANT over the
mutant type which is the white eye trait.
Getting back to the experiment, Morgan assumed
that the genes for the trait are present on
“X” chromosome.
Let us also ASSUME the same and begin crossing
and see if we get the same results!
So we have X with ‘w in lower case’ for
representing the genes that give white coloured
eyes, and we have “X with w plus” for
representing the wild type that is the red
coloured eyes.
Now we begin the crossing of the white eyed
male with the red eyed female.
The cross yields all the offsprings with red
eyes in the F1 generation.
This is how the genes are passed to the progeny.
Now the next step is crossing the offsprings
from this F1 generation.
On crossing these two with red eyes, we get
a progeny that is in the ratio 3 to 1.
So we have got three that are red eyed and
one that is white eyed.
To be precise, we obtain one male with red
eyes, and two females which are red eyed.
The only white eyed fly is this male here.
Morgan obtained this same result if you remember!
So this assumption we made gave us the same
results as Morgan’s cross.
Hence the assumption that the genes for eye
colour are present on the “X” chromosome
in fruit flies is correct!
What if the alleles would have been present
on “Y” chromosome?
Then the trait would have been visible ONLY in males.
That is because in organisms like Drosophila,
males have one X chromosome and one Y chromosome
and females have both ‘X’ chromosomes.
To summarise, this experiment helped Morgan
to prove that genes are present on chromosomes.
Also, he could find out that the genes for
eye colour were present on the "X" chromosome
in the fruit fly.
This also indicated the fact that genes are
passed from one generation to the other!
This is how Mendelian genetics as well as
Sutton and Boveri’s chromosomal theory of
inheritance were both proved better with Morgan’s
experiments!